Another interesting thing that happened this weekend as a result of
Donald Trump's little Twitter tirade
is that we had National Intelligence officials
who were meeting overseas to discuss
the Russian interference who had to tell them
"Hey, please disregard what The President is tweeting,
we're going to take this issue seriously,
we're going to do something about it."
Because based on what Donald Trump was sending out Saturday morning
everybody pretty much got the impression that he doesn't care.
All he wants to do is shift blame.
He wants to say "this was Obama", "This guy did this, the guy before me
so now he's gone, so now we've got nothing to worry about"
Well, no. The intelligence community
has been warning us for quite some time now
that Russian could try to interfere
in the 2018 midterm elections.
One of the main reasons we kind of wanted those sanctions
just to let them know that they're not going to get away with it.
Trump's not doing anything about it, doesn't
seem to care, doesn't really mind
that Russians might interfere again. Why?
Because it's going to be to the benefit of Republicans.
I mean, I think it's hilarious
that he's out there, trying to say that Obama was
covering it up. Or, that they interfered
on behalf of Hillary Clinton
because, according to Trump and some of the hardcore MAGA crowd
The Russians wanted Hillary Clinton to win, it just didn't
go their way. So, "even with Russian interference
she still managed to lose the election" is one of the
talking points that we've got going around right now. But look,
all of this underscores the biggest problem there is -
The Russians interfered.
Maybe it was sanctioned
by the Russian government. The jury is still out on that.
But regardless, something has to happen
and one of the biggest things that has to happen
is on us. It's on Americans.
We have to learn to differentiate
between fake news, propaganda
and real, honest reporting.
Because they can throw all the propaganda
that they want at us
and if we're dumb enough to believe it
then they succeed. You know, recently
there was this organization
that had come up with, essentially, a standardized test of sorts.
And they were going around the country, and they said "this will help
teach high-school students how to differentiate
between fake news and honest reporting".
Countries like Great Britain decided to implement it
so they can start teaching young high-school students
how to differentiate between
the two. Other countries have also adopted this. The US
declined. They didn't want to be a part of this, you know,
testing, or curriculum
to teach our children how to
tell the difference between
journalism and fake news propaganda.
And why could that be? Well,
because an uninformed electorate,
people who cannot tell the difference between fiction and reality,
benefits the Republicans. We have already
seen, in the last few weeks, study after study
come out, saying that Donald Trump supporters
were far more likely
to share these fake news stories, to share
these propaganda memes on social media
than Democrats or Progressives.
It works.
The fake news being pushed
out there, the hashtags, all of the propaganda
worked on this particular group of people.
And our government doesn't want to teach them
the difference because they're the ones
who benefited from it.
So that's where we are right now with the  Mueller investigation.
We have a lot of question marks
we're getting a lot more answers and according to
James Clapper, Fmr. Director of National Intelligence for the US,
the big shoe
is probably still yet to drop.
Recently, in an interview, James Clapper
said that he believes that Robert Mueller
is most likely going after Donald Trump's personal
and professional finances and when he finds
whatever it is he's looking for,
that is going to be the next big shoe to drop
in this investigation. Now, Clapper
admitted that he's not a part of then investigation and that proclamation,
I guess, was pure speculation;
He doesn't know for sure what they're going after.
But he does know
that Robert Mueller knows more about this investigation than
anyone else. He does know
that European banks
have been subpoenaed for records regarding Donald Trump's
personal finances, professional finances.
So, it does seem likely, based on the available
evidence, that Clapper could be 100%
correct - the next big shoe, after
this indictment of Friday that we just had -
could be the finances of Donald Trump himself
and his businesses. Because, as we know, and we'll talk
about this more after the break, Jared Kushner's
finances, right now, are suddenly
in the spot light and that's not going to end well for anybody.
I'm Farron Cousins, sitting in for David Pakman.
You can follow me on Twitter @FarronBallanced
Also, visit our website at TROfire.com.
We'll be right back.
If I gave you the task of picking out a wine
that you were definitely going to love, with
the catch that it has to be a wine you've not tried before,
what would you even do? I'd be clueless because
I know nothing about wine. But one possibility would be to check out
today's sponsor Winc, spelled W-i-n-c,
which makes it
easy for you to discover great wines. Every month
they ship you wines that have been matched
to your taste and personalized to you.
These are wines you're going to like and they're shipped
right to your door. You just open them up and enjoy.
And, unlike the grocery store that won't help you
select wines or deliver them to your door,
with Winc you get to explore rare and interesting bottles
from around the world that are tailored
to your taste.
You go to TryWinc.com/pakman and try out their
palate profile quiz. They will as you really
simple questions like "how do you like your coffee?", "Do you like
raspberries or blueberries?" and then
the great wines just start to show up, personalized to you
and delivered right to your door.
As you drink wine and rate wine
the system will send you even better personalized
selections that you can try
from one month to the next.
And, of course, no membership fees, skip any month,
cancel any time and there's a 100% satisfaction guarantee
so you never pay for a bottle you don't like.
And for a limited time
you can get 20$ off when you go to TryWinc.com/pakman
TryWinc.com/pakman
for 20$ off.